(bass driven rock music)
- [Sam Voiceover] This.
This is it.
The spot where comics go after
the show to just shoot the shit.
Tonight, I'm here to work,
to write new material.
- I'll have the usual.
Thanks, doll. (laughs)
- Sam!
My man.
How we doin'?
- Oh, hey Mark.
- It's Tim.
- Right, right, right.
I'm good.
You know, just doing
shows, the norm.
- Oh, yes.
Isn't it the best?
All I need is a
microphone in front of me,
and a brick wall behind me,
and that raw truth
just takes over.
No bullshit.
- Right, right, right, right.
Yeah, same.
Just a bare bones
comedian here. (laughs)
- Thank you, Reggie.
- It's actually Luke.
- Oh my God.
You two are literally
obsessed with names.
- Yo, when the
crowd is in my hand,
comedians are like rock stars.
Hold on, wait, we're like
the new philosophers.
Oh wait, we're like those--
- Yeah, I'm actually
trying to write
right now, so could you not?
I mean, not trying
to be rude, just.
- [Sam Voiceover] Okay,
now back to writing.
New material.
It's gotta be honest.
No, I need to be now.
I need to tackle the
political climate.
Yes!
This is it.
Hard hitting, honest,
and political.
I don't know, maybe
it's too harsh.
I'm not Bill Hicks, after all.
- There it is.
My new bit.
- Is that a bit?
Yeah, that's a bit.
I like that, 'cause it's like,
is Macri dead?
I don't know! (laughs)
- I know, right?
- Keep that, keep that.
- I'm incredible. (laughs)
Pills for the bar.